So to give a response then, you'd actually just swap the
source and destination ports, and the source and destination IP addresses.
The path back will feel just like the path forward, though
it's possible that it will follow a different set of hops.
And of course it will be in the reverse. When the
packet gets back, to the mo, router at your house, it
will swap out the IP and port for the correct ones
as part of the network address translation. It's routing table will
then tell it the MAC address of your computer, so that
it can be put in a packet in a link layer frame
and passed back to your computer. Now, to complete the handshake,
and establish the TCP connection, your computer needs to send back an
acknowledgement to Udacity. This will be almost exactly the same as
the first packet with just a small change to the TCP header.
Indeed all the communication will feel much like this, only instead
of sending packets with no contents, Udacity will send each other real
data, with the TCP headers, IP headers, and then sometimes on and
off during the transmission, the link layer headers and footers as well.